we have heard bulgur and this is
rhetoric so if you see somebody getting
ready to throw a tomato knock the crap
out of avoid you i will pay for the
legal fees i promise aimed with women
and minorities it was blood coming out
of her eyes blood coming out of her
wherever they're bringing crime they're
rapists and americans who don't look
like us or prey like us I think Islam
hates us or vote like we do there's a
guy totally disruptive like to punch him
in the face I'll tell you as we've seen
actual violence longer that we tacitly
accepted we create a permission
structure America has always attracted
the greatest talent from every corner of
the globe why would we want to see that
brand tarnish the world pays attention
to what we say and what we do apologies
for freedom